when it what what do you think of like
uh uh if if somebody you know like the
stories you read about uh there's this
one book called the Ageless man I don't
know if you've read the book ageless man
yeah where the guy says you're you're
you're not healthier if you're stero if
your testosterone level is lower you
need to be like nowadays A lot of people
aren't trt more than people would know
there's a lot of people that are in the
NBA that are using stuff there's a lot
of guys that are in the NFL using stuff
there's a lot of people that are in
politics content creators a lot of
people Hollywood movie stars you saw Joe
Rogan calling out The Rock The Rock
needs to come out and do what you know
him did how many people you think are on
stuff that we don't know about oh I have
no idea you know I mean I I don't know
you know I tell my kids this all the
time you know and if I say this to
anyone who engages with me like don't
compare yourself to me don't compare
yourself to anybody right I mean one of
the most famous lines I say non-stop is
to express your highest the most
dominant form right compare yourself to
yourself right because obviously once
you start doing this like well how the
[ __ ] are you ever going to measure right
you're never going to measure right so
do these things these are the ways of
our early ancestors this is how we honor
the struggle of our early ancestors this
is how you can express your highest and
most dominant form I have no idea you
know like who's on just trt or I mean I
guess we would have an idea of who's on
more than trt you know but um but uh
this is not a conversation that I
generally have yeah because I mean trt I
watched like from Facebook and
everything trt there there's it's it's
they're promoting it everywhere you know
I mean on Facebook you I I get all that
where you go get the test and they
they'll they'll tell you where your
testosterone is at and they'll send it
literally to your door it's not illegal
right trt correct yeah it's not it's not
like a trt is not the big deal so what
up my question because I really don't
know is the growth the thing that people
are saying that that's a steroid I mean
it's not like anabolic like um like Deca
or all that other stuff I mean what's I
don't see like the big problem with it I
think you could categorize it it's a
poor performance enhancing drug yeah you
know technically it's not a steroid
hormone it's a peptide hormone but
there's no doubt that it's helped with
performance and Recovery there's no
doubt you know I had a close friend say
hey you should not say you're taking
steroids you should tell people what
you're taking which is testosterone and
growth hormone yeah and I'm like you
know what what I've done is I've
undershared let me over share at least
yeah I'm taking steroids yeah I've been
on steroids I'm on steroids you know
right now which is testosterone and
growth hormone I would say growth
hormone has played a significant role
you know and help it be to recover to
help me get in the gym as many times as
I want to I do think it has made a big
difference but at 100 percent is through
a clinician through a trained
professional monitored and managed and
everything is written as a prescription
so and I'm probably like just I mean
health-wise and I'm happy that you're
doing it the right way and doing all
that like health-wise for future stuff
are you worried because I mean there's
only so much the heart and the body can
actually take no matter what a doctor
says do you have any worries about that
ever like catching up or like a heart
attack or something crazy you know what
I did and um you know early on I also
was on Deca and Winstrol and so my blood
chemistry was all [ __ ] yeah it was all
was all deranged
um and I'm like you know I'm here to be
a dad I'm here to be a husband like I
don't I if if this is gonna [ __ ] this up
I'm gonna get off this uh and so that
was pretty clear I mean we we
discontinued um the DECA and the
winstrong and the blood chemistries look
good perfect yeah it's great
um so I mean again like I think it's
very nuanced who should even consider
this right for a young man don't don't
even think about it I mean there's no
steroid there's no form of any steroid
that's appropriate for a 15 year old or
a young man or even 18 or because I mean
your body's producing it you're just
you're just throwing money down the
toilet your body's you're in Prime
testosterone you're on stage exactly
yeah but there is there is one thing
that you know that I uh uh I'm sure
you're already planning for this when
Adam asked you know you're going to
continue like I've made a decision I'm
going to get off of it
four years you know of being testing
with these different things to get off
you're gonna need to get off with
somebody that's watching and monitoring
because you like you said I don't know
the side effects I've only been doing it
for 40s that was a perfect answer it's
like I've been doing it for four years
yeah and
it's not easy to get off of stuff you
know it's a it's a challenge and it's
best to have somebody very close that's
telling you what to do when you are
getting off of this stuff I got a
brilliant friend who knows a lot about
this where do you live you live in
Austin right you're in Austin or I'm
between Houston and Dallas but okay got
it um I I just also want to say this is
my plan to do that
this might not work out but this is my
plan to do this and I believe meaning
get on off of it may not work out yeah
it might not work out meaning you may
get back on it you know what again
that's not my intention but like let's
say it's been three or four months let's
say that I
I have no cognitive ability my physical
bit you know like I've just the will
you're gonna feel it bro I've been
reading I've been reading and I'm like
oh my God like this is this is are you
are you in contact with any major
bodybuilders or no no okay are you open
to the idea of to talking to somebody
absolutely okay would you mind if I put
you in contact I would appreciate it
yeah because they can tell you stuff I
can't and I'm going to put you in
contact with like the main guys
that they'll talk to you about this
because I would not suddenly there's
certain things you can do cold turkey I
I don't know if it's that Health you got
to tell you something everybody so this
morning uh I don't know if it was Andrew
Schultz or one of the his co-hosts yeah
Onsen when's the last time you did
steroids and I saw I had a shot on
Saturday I go oh [ __ ] you know what
actually today I had I did growth I did
growth hormones every day I had a growth
hormone today and and this is the thing
like I know that you can't just come off
with a cold turkey you know I know that
there's a plan there's a way to do it an
intelligent way to do it I also know
it's going to be what I've read it's
really hard to do and I'm sure there's
best practices you know to transition to
at least lessen that but but what I'm
really hoping to do is like I'm gonna
give that everything I'm gonna give that
a shot yeah just just just be before you
because okay so right now there's
there's a few things that is going on
that you're you're going through your
you're going through something that
you've never gone through before which
is what public apology let me go talk to
a few of the guys that I respect and
they're they're going to be able to do
this in a respectful manner just make
sure you're not making commitments
that's going to be very hard to and
don't say publicly because there's he
did it again he did it again so it's
just like like what you just said I
don't know I don't know what's going to
happen all I'm saying is if you're
you want to get off of wheat you know
how they say like you gotta when you're
dropping a bad habit you got to replace
with something else okay there's a big
difference of getting off of steroids
and stop drinking alcohol or stop
smoking weed you get off of wheat okay
maybe you're gonna chew or smoke cigars
or something that you're replacing it
with the original replacing growth
hormone and steroids with something else
that's gonna fill the need in your body
that's not because
wheat is not dramatically you know or
this is my thing you get what I'm saying
maybe I'm wrong about this but I'm
convinced that it's my obsession with
over training that's that's screwing up
my hormones you know that that I think
that if if I can fix away and find a way
to not have to do this two or three
times a day and just do it at least once
a day I think if I do it once a day get
into the gym at least once a day and not
do two or three times a day
um I think because over training clearly
has an effect on your hormone profile
and again I know that there's a whole
other thing to consider about I'm not
producing any of my natural stuff right
now you know there's a negative feedback
going on how am I going to get my own
natural stuff going on but but then it's
really addressing the root cause and I
believe the root the root cause well the
root cause is really these self-worth
things that I got to deal with and I got
to go deep with but then I also got to
say listen
um I'm not going to go into the gym two
or three times a day you know I know
that I got to figure out a way to sleep
I know that I got to figure out a way to
recover I know that I got to figure out
a lot of this stuff any connections with
anybody who has experience with it oh
dude I want to give you the right people
and you talk to them and my
recommendation is to be very methodical
with the right support before you go
through this transition bro I'm just
telling you it's I saw one guy go
through it you want to talk about like
like uh hardcore anxiety like emotional
breakdown depression it's not it's it's
a serious thing so this is not something
you go sudden cold turkey and there's
certain things you you've you've read
about all this stuff how to naturally
increase your testosterone love a
deadlift squats all this certain things
you eat to naturally also increase but
you're going to go through it you're
going to go through it it's it's a it's
a thing but with the right support and
the right counsel you're going to go
through it's going to be fine so what
all the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks right here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
or black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bad toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]